jour après jour la pression devient de
plus en plus forte
les échanges de tir sont incessants
dans les rues de châssivia les immeubles
sont désertés il n'y a plus aucun enfant
les parcs sont abandonnés
sur la place centrale devant le palais
de la culture quelques résidences sont
venus chercher de l'aide humanitaire de
la farine des vivres il se dépêche
ensuite de se mettre à l'abri
les avions les explosions tout tremblent
et ça ne cesse jamais c'est qui tout ce
que tu as joué
mentalement on a peur bien sûr dit-elle
mais on doit l'endurer j'espère que nous
ennemis seront punis après tout ce
qu'ils ont fait
la ligne de front n'est qu'à quelques
kilomètres sur la colline un canon
ukrainien ces deux-là qu'on tire vers
les positions russes et verbarmouth la
ville est aussi un point de
ravitaillement pour les troupes
nous nous arrêtons à l'un des derniers
magasins encore ouvert on y trouve des
biens essentiels de la nourriture aussi
et dans le fond une chanson de Céline
Dion joue à la radio
[Musique]
on vivait ensemble russe et ukrainien
d'inadiejda c'était bien avant pourquoi
ils veulent nous diviser maintenant pour
eux l'Ukraine fait partie de la Russie
même s'ils ne le disent pas ouvertement
par crainte de représailles abdoulah
oui je suis né j'ai grandi en Union
soviétique et je n'ai jamais compris
nous dit-elle la séparation de l'Ukraine
un atlas du temps l'URSS traîne au bord
de la fenêtre
on les sent amer ils ont le sentiment
d'avoir été négligés oubliés par les
autorités ukrainiennes depuis
l'indépendance
vous avez vu notre ville dit son mari
tout est détruit il n'y a plus d'usine
comme le reste du pays d'ailleurs
c'était bien différent il y a 30 ans
à l'autre bout de la ville la
distribution se termine Tamara et sa
fille ont reçu plusieurs sacs de farine
pour elle et pour leurs voisins de quoi
tenir plusieurs jours mais elles n'ont
que de la colère envers le peuple russe
pourrir Diala après tout ce qu'ils nous
ont fait tout ça c'est la faute du mot
dipoutine sans lui il n'y aurait jamais
eu de guerre ici chacun a fait son choix
les deux camps cohabitent encore mais
peut-être plus pour longtemps le sort de
la ville se dessine en ce moment même à
quelques kilomètres plus à l'est